okay now I don't pretend to be an avid
football fan but like millions of people
up and down the country I can't help but
get caught up in the euphoria of
watching England play especially Gareth
Southgate talented team that represent
the rich diverse makeup of modern
Britain as I wrote in the Sun earlier
this week it broke my heart to read the
England and Spurs defender Danny Rose is
counting down the days until his
football career is over and this sad
news is not because he no longer enjoys
the game but rather he can no longer
stand the racist abuse that he and other
black players are subjected to both here
and abroad when it comes to tackling
racism in football the FA and UEFA have
been at best well-meaning but
ineffective and at worse indifferent
this is completely unacceptable if we
truly want football to come home in all
its glory
then we need to defend the dignity of
all our players otherwise we will lose
the talents and passion of players and
fans from all backgrounds just a warning
this debate may contain language that
some viewers might find offensive nobody
could argue with what you've just said
but but questions this is not a new
problem you know I stopped going to my
club which is a London club
approximately 35 years ago because I was
in the middle of our famous that stand
and I was like there was a period when
they were throwing darts and I was like
the bullseye in the middle of this stand
because one black face I never got hit
by a dart but the problem is there are
two things here which we've got to deal
with first of all what did the players
do should they walk or shouldn't they
walk and some think that they should
rain sterling says not I think I'm sort
of temperamentally with sterling I think
that you always have to confront racism
walk away from it
a separate and bigger issue I think
which is the truth is this is about
football crowds and it is not as I think
people would like to make it about
tattooed boot boys I mean actually we
got rid of most of those but do you
think for me my issue with this is I
believe of course we have to deal with
the fans but I think it's the
effectiveness of the FA and a new way
for that is what has upset me the most
of all of this because actually the
bodies that are supposed to be
protecting our players are doing nothing
and I think that's what the frustration
is for the Danny roses and the Raheem
Sterling's of this world is that
something happens and they see
absolutely nothing done Oh a miniscule
fine that you know isn't gonna impact
that person in any way shape or form I
just want to quickly bring in Rose's
actual statement and then it'd be great
to hear more and then we'll get the rest
of the panel min he says there is so
much politics and whatever in football
and I just can't wait to see the back of
it to be honest
obviously it is a bit sad but when
countries only get fined what I'd
probably spend on a night out in London
what do you expect and I think that's
what's hurting him it's not so much what
happened it's the fact that there is no
sort of justice afterwards yes so we
just hear what the affair and say about
this as well I think it's important so
the FA is dedicated to putting a stop to
racism in football it's time to examine
where for three step process for holding
matches the protocol ask the referee to
stop the match of racist behavior is of
a strong magnitude and intensity but I
don't now think that is good enough
there should be no judgment call on
whether something is of a strong magnet
magnitude racism is racism and I agree
with him and I think that you do need to
make sure that you because I think
football often represents a lot of
what's going on in society and you
yourself very recently he was subject to
a racist attack and you know I think
that sometimes especially in football I
think people drink a lot before they go
to the games sometimes and then they
come
he knew their drinking when they get to
the stadium sometimes which isn't
helping the situation so I just think
there needs to be a very clear strong
message that this will not be tolerated
if you are seen to be doing this you'll
just be stripped of your you'll see and
your ticket end of story
all your club will be heavily fine so
therefore they will make sure that they
enact some sort of policy to help
prevent yeah I'm just really surprised
that it's some I had been under the
false belief that all of this had been
dealt with after we grew up in a very
difficult and very difficult
circumstances and it's the years of the
murder of Stephen Lawrence and I used to
refer to them as the bad old days of
racism in this country and I'm just I'm
just worried that it's no longer the old
part of that sort of sentence no longer
it's still going on and it appears to me
that this stuff was buried and something
is emboldened certain types of people
for it to come back out to the forefront
and it usually is in the game you
stopped going to the game I've never
been to a game and that's the reason I
was born and raised in Essex and we knew
from the beginning that that's just not
what you did
you didn't go to football matches
because you didn't end up with your head
kicked in and that's why in fact my very
first ever memory of a racist attack and
this is you mentioned this one it's
actually one in a long line of many but
my very first ever memory of it was at
the age of around ten and a half years
old and I was in the playground and I
was attacked punched in the stomach
because I asked to join a game of
football and I never played in school
ever again as a result because as they
attack me they said this game is a pakis
and the guy hit me really hard in the
stomach it's the first time I was ever
hit so machine the back of those days
and now you've got me thinking as to
what is it that's bringing them bringing
this kind of these attitudes back out to
the fore nothing but sympathy for Danny
Rose he's been subjected and I'm gonna
give you an idea you talked about the
level of fines it's laughable when you
think what money is in the game I'll
tell you just once I will get there just
women it's interesting I can't wait to
see the end but Ethan's committee so do
another three or four years which if he
that is awful
you can't make a man go through four
years of having being jeered at this
level will tell you what UEFA says
interesting
get an idea of the fine jun you've
mentioned this a couple of times so in
the past you a for a fine Serbia
sixty-five thousand pounds for racism
and violence by their fans towards
England under-21s during a match in 2012
that's from UEFA and then you wait to
find one particular player he plays for
Denmark
Nicklas Bendtner 80,000 pounds for
lowering his shorts to reveal underwear
with a Paddy Power logo after scoring a
match in 2012 so you get 65,000 pounds
for racism violence for showing your
underwear
what does UEFA say Gianni Infantino UEFA
general secretary UEFA is committed to
tackling discrimination in football and
really encourages all fans to join our
efforts and to value respect respect for
players respect for officials for the
referees for the opposite side for all
fans for fellow supporters of all
nationalities of all ethnic backgrounds
of all sexual orientations respect for
everyone there you go on what we care
about in football is the color of the
shirt not the color of the skin
commitment and our ambition is to stamp
out racism and xenophobia out of
football and when you say just last you
you say we are defending the dignity
I think I think England is not doing
about sorry the United Kingdom I'm sure
the same in Scotland and Northern Iowa I
think the UK is not doing a bad job in
these countries if you look at some
Eastern European countries that are
clearly so retrograde and that's where
the fines have to hit I think I don't
know if I totally agree with you because
if you look at Anton Ferdinand and John
Terry case I think that was badly
handled and if I was Anton Ferdinand and
part the reason why Rios said he didn't
sort of finish out was because of that
and I think actually if I was a football
and seeing that again and again after a
while you just there's lots of good
statements and there's lots of kind of
demand and outrage and all the rest of
it
but I wonder if some of the outrage is
basically missing the real target who
are the fans because you know there are
football clubs where the Y word
referring to Jews
every single week there is a well-known
I'd rather be a [ __ ] than whatever for
example my point is if we really want to
do something about this then actually
what you're gonna have to do to clear
the stadiums the fans are going to have
to be punished what's happening here is
the atmosphere when you get in there
it's quite I mean I now go back I took
my daughter and some many years ago to
her first football match seven years old
in the most expensive stand in English
football at the time
halfway through two blokes jump up in
front of us shouting at Carlton Palmer
black player you lanky legged black
something for what four letters and they
look round at us and go look at these
children didn't mean any offense by the
way three weeks later I was at a posh
reception in the City of London and I
walked into the guy who did that senior
lawyer in a city firm my point is this
is act about the culture of the game
[Music]
because he he takes the viewer actually
the player shouldn't walk off I
personally he says wouldn't agree with
walking off to win the game would hurt
them even more they're only trying to
get you down if you walk off they win to
score or win would be better he's done a
lot it's a challenge racism is something
else he said he's he said he doesn't
think he can solve it and that speaks to
the earlier point that I thought this
stuff I thought had gone away let's come
back again and all he said is look I
don't think I can solve it all I can do
is raise awareness around it which is
what this debates about I suppose well